شهدت السنوات الاخيره زياده في نسبه
الاشخاص الذين يعانون من الارق في مختلف
دول العالم الارق هو احد اكثر اضطرابات
النوم شيوعا حيث يصيب ما بين 10 الى 30%
من سكان العالم وفقا لما ذكرته المكتب
الوطني للطب تصل النسبه في بعض البلدان
الى خمسين وستين في المئه يصيب الارق
النساء اكثر من الرجال بنسبه 40% وينتشر
عند كبار السن والاشخاص الذين يعانون من
مشاكل صحيه او اضطرابات نفسيه او عقليه
ويصيب اكثر ذوي الدخل المنخفض تشير
الدراسات الى ان الارقى نوعان الارق
المؤقت الذي يصيب الاشخاص لفتره قصيره
والارق المزمن لفترات متقطعه ويستمر الى
بضعه اسابيع تعزى الاسباب الى التغيرات
المجتمعيه لا سيما انشغال الناس
بالتكنولوجيا وضغوط العمل اضافه الى زياده
معدلات السمنه ومرض كما تشير الدراسات الى
ان الارقة قد يكون وراثيا حيث ان حوالي
35% من المصابين لديهم تاريخ عائلي في هذا
الصدد
[موسيقى]